sometimes luck just
isn't on your side and i don't mean
literal rng luck i mean the universe
just hates you in esports when you hear
someone call a player unlucky it's
because everything that could go wrong
does go wrong and all your teammates can
say is well never lucky but before we
get started i want to remind you all as
always to hit the subscribe button
because i don't want you to be unlucky
and miss one of our amazing videos now
let's get into the top 10 unlucky
moments in esports
starting off our list at number 10 is
the time dapper had one too many
obstacles between him and the diffuser
no he's still going to miss right clicks
from dapper and it's still a w from envy
it is shambles it's disastrous but it's
a tie score line at three to three at
the vct three n a challenger's playoffs
sentinels were facing off against envy
with a trip to masters berlin on the
line during round six dapper was in a
1v1 against marved with just one hp and
a classic but dapper had the element of
surprise because marv was sticking the
defuse unfortunately for dapper things
just weren't that easy oh god the domain
expansion in the mid side as the site's
a little bit bigger marv there's more
space to stretch out in and potentially
some more cheese how close the rifle
sees the barrel songs is going to go
down zapper now into 1v1 only one hp
left oh from up top no
no he's still going to miss right clicks
from dapper and it's still a w from envy
it is shambles it's disastrous but it's
a tie score line at three to three
for starters dapper should have seen
marv once he jumped up to nest but there
was a viper wall hiding him perfectly
zen dapper got his second chance with an
opportunity to fire point blank shots
into the back of marv's head
but he missed the shots
never lucky
it's a morphed moment
oh my god he went down dapper is uno
you can't see [ __ ]
coming in at number nine is one of the
most painful entries on this list it's
canadian and his unlucky moment against
team empire
young will be the last one left he was
so important for faze he turns his back
he's got the pistol but shepard will
deny the comeback from eg on that round
in the grand finals of r6 pro league
season 9 eg were on match point up 6-4
over empire on oregon canadian was
holding white stairs and for reasons no
one can explain he got a little too
antsy canadian peeked and it went all
downhill from there down on white stairs
waiting for the vault on in his canadian
will he be able to secure the kill he
sees the tracers go oh no scyther will
win the fight he'll inch his way on up
geo's gonna be next in line but this
could be a tough shot and empire could
wrestle away the round there's geo just
waiting he doesn't pull the trigger he
sees it he pops up oh no geo you gotta
hit your shots young will be the last
one left he was so important for faze he
turns his back he's got the pistol but
shepard will deny the comeback from eg
on that round
bad timing unforced ego peak bad spray
control
take your pick losing a 3v2 is just
unlucky and this moment led to a full-on
choke from eg who lost the tournament to
empire
evil geniuses tossing it away empire
seizing the opportunity
taking the eighth spot on this list is
the unfortunate time falling couldn't
quite land a hit on adren through the
smoke i wanna
i wanna call him to a corner and cry for
fallen in his long and storied career
fallen has gotten some pretty
unbelievable kills despite not being
able to see his enemies they're gonna be
able to get the bomb plant and happy
even waiting for the push in fallen gets
the spray shot anyway
what is what
what is that
but when facing off against team liquid
at the eye by power fall invitational in
2016 fong got a little unlucky when he
not only missed an off shot through the
smoke but also somehow whipped the knife
kill as well fallen eventually hits him
and fallen gets another one out of the
connector and the trench trying to get
up on toll booth as bugley removes cold
we're gonna be two on two here that
one's got a three steel piece out able
to take down fugly adren gets himself
into the palm site gets on the bomb
either try and hold here ends up taking
down steel gets back onto the bomb let's
see if he can hold it for long enough
you can hear it in the caster's voice
just look how close that op shot was
then it looks like fallen was too early
on the knife kill by what a single frame
come on man
falling into seventh place is the time
plop fell victim to a 20 year old glitch
unreal
[Applause]
if you're at all familiar with melee's
pokemon stadium stage you'll know that
it is a hellscape there are a ton of
clipping issues character-specific
glitches and other general nonsense that
gives the map a bad reputation but one
of the biggest problems is how sometimes
on the fire transformation of the stage
players can just fall through the floor
if everything goes perfectly wrong
all right can suj put together a johnny
stalker are we going to see pluck go up
2-0
for the first time could we see oh what
the hell
are you kidding me the pokemon glitch in
top eight and shine unreal freeze this
map raise this map
now being the sixth spot on our list is
the time g2 found themselves searching
for the bomb on the wrong side
there could be absolutely no way this
can't be real oh no g2 holy [ __ ]
this can't be real how have they done
that no
in the new legend stage of the 2019
berlin major astralis were up on match
point against g2 but g2 fought back
valiantly they wiped out astralis and
had plenty of time to spare to defuse
the bomb now nuke is unique in the way
that has both bomb sites stacked on top
of each other and let's just say csgo's
sound design has an age as gracefully as
the rest of the game
g2 were somehow convinced that the bomb
was on a when it was actually on b the
bomb ticked away as g2 either completely
forgot there was another bomb site or
they just you know decided to lose on
purpose if it wasn't for that double
kill from shocks triple kill make that
beautiful round on the defense but you
could see the the idea behind that from
astralis get that plant down so quickly
you have someone looking hot you have
device lurking
wait he's doing it with the kit what are
they doing they're not finding the bomb
no no no no no no no
holy [ __ ]
this cannot be real how have they done
that
no well you won't see that and we've
seen ninja diffusers i've never seen a
ninja ball ever in my life before
whether it's bad communication or the
infamous sound issues on nuke that's
just unlucky
cracking our top five is the time mad
lions kaiser died to raptors of all
things p hanami gets chased away
humanoid on the chase for that one
kaiser will finally die
to kai wing i don't know if he ignited
him on the very back end he's oh no i
think he accidentally aggroed the
chickens and the chickens murdered him
i'm pretty sure that's what it was ever
been in the wrong place at the wrong
time well that's exactly what happened
to kaiser when he died to a jungle camp
mad blind managed to get a kill onto kai
wing but kaiser was low as a result so
we had to get out of there however just
as he was passing a raptor camp his
eclipse ability popped aggroing the
vicious chickens and leading to his
unlucky and embarrassing demise over
onto kaiser kaiser with the ignite
getting very very low he does survive
and yeah oh it's the w expiration there
the w pop over the wall aggregate
you can see the shock on his face
because you're not even thinking about
it
our fourth spot goes to every sorry soul
that has ever had the displeasure of
falling off of vertigo closer and closer
to overtime
oh no
he has done it
vertigo is
well it's a map in cs go i guess it's
extremely controversial thanks to its
insane angles and aggressive rotates but
it's also not a safe space for the
acrophobic vertigo takes place on top of
a building which of course you can fall
off of and trust us people have fallen
off this stupid thing
oh my
g
stats one instead
pour one out for all the bodies
surrounding the base of whatever
unfinished building this is
taking our third spot on our list is
rops and the time he got outplayed by a
chicken a chicken blocking the door just
got robbed killed
love to see it
yes for the second time on this list a
chicken is to blame for a player's
misfortune
back at the star series eye league
season four finals mouse sports were
facing off against sk gaming but robs
should have paid more attention to his
real enemy a stray chicken wandering the
map and robs just backs off with all the
information he doesn't play off the back
of it he tries to help his team out on b
but it's too little and too late fur has
done a massive job
10 seconds left rob's has to hold on to
his gun chicken blocking the door i've
not seen that before if that gets him
killed oh my god a chicken blocking the
door just got robbed killed
love to see it
luckily mousesports still won the series
but could you imagine the door stuck
meme leading to a loss
unlucky
coming in second place is the time
hanabi got chased across the world by a
turret now that's an unlucky feels bad
man right there okay there's not a whole
lot to say about this one but this might
be the epitome of unlucky kanami made
the unfortunate mistake of tping into a
team fight while he was already being
targeted by an enemy tower he already
started taking hits before reaching the
fight and with the damage king zone put
on him when he got there he couldn't
survive the final shot
yeah
look at this i mean it was definitely a
spread out one and that was the actual
last hit that finished off out of me
taking the top spot on our list is nico
and is now infamous with at the
stockholm major
nico doesn't miss
[Applause]
no
no v they they fight on and you can see
here that that no timeout listen it
happened simple finally won his major
unfortunately to get there we had to
watch niko with what should have been a
simple shot
times it to perfection
and simple sitting no no
an absolute disaster
pound for pound nico is the greatest
deagle player of all time but when it
mattered most the gun just didn't want
to cooperate with him missing a shot on
game point and losing a major
nico we're sorry dude that's just
unlucky
and that's our list you think we missed
an unlucky moment in esports let us know
down in the comment section below take
care and i'll see you in the next one
i remember specifically there was this
one time when i was playing super mario
galaxy too and you can go like really
really quickly in super mario galaxy too
and i just like for the life of me could
not understand the physics of like
eating a pepper going up like
essentially a warped wall
two hours on just that one section of
the level and i could not do it and i
still haven't done it i am 23 years old
and i have not completed that level yet